So we always have to keep in mind that the order in some
sense gets reversed.
The operation performed
first is the one on the right and the operation that gets performed last or in this case, second,
is the one on the left.
If we don't stop with the second operation and we apply all of them in
order starting with the first and ending with the last one, which is Mn,
then the composition of all
of these operations together is given by this product
that you see right here,
and you see that the ordering
once again is reversed for exactly the same reason as before.
So in short, compositions
of probabilistic operations are represented by products
of stochastic matrices that represent them.
Keeping in mind that this is
the ordering of the matrices in the product.
You will always get a stochastic matrix by taking a product of
stochastic matrices like this, and sometimes we express this fact
by saying that the stochastic
matrices are closed under multiplication, and the way that you
can think about this is that you can't get out of the
set of stochastic matrices
by multiplying them because the set is closed.
Getting back to the
ordering of the matrices in this product, it's important to note that the
ordering really does matter.
Matrix multiplication is not commutative. If you change the ordering of
the matrices in the product, you might change the result,
and we don't need to look any further than the deterministic
operations to see this.
Here's a simple example of
two stochastic matrices, both of which represent
deterministic operations where the ordering matters.
M1 represents the constant zero function. Assuming, we're imagining that these two operations are on bits, just like in the example from earlier.
M2 represents the not
operation or a bit flip.
If you perform M1 first
and then you perform M2, the result is this matrix right here, which represents the
constant one function.
If you set a bit to zero
and then you flip it, it's the same thing as just
setting that bit to one.
On the other hand, if you perform M2 first
and then you perform M1, this is the result right here,
and this makes sense because if you flip a bit
and then you set it to zero, it's the same thing as
just setting it to zero.
It didn't matter that you flipped it. Obviously, these two
matrices are not the same, and so we have a very
simple example revealing
that the order does matter. Of course, this is not surprising at all.
We all know that the order in which
operations are performed matters or at least, it can matter.
For example, if you light a
match and then you blow on it, the result is very different
from blowing on the match first
and then lighting it. At this point, we've talked quite a lot
about classical information and now it's finally time to
discuss quantum information.
And what we'll find is that
mathematically speaking, quantum information works
in a very similar way to classical information
with some key differences.
The first key difference
is right at the start, how we define a state, in this case, a quantum state of a system,
and there is a sense in which this one choice how
we define a quantum state largely determines how
quantum information works.
We'll also define how
measurements and operations work, and in the next lesson, we'll discuss how
quantum information works not just for single systems
but for multiple systems,
but these things actually
follow pretty naturally once the notion of a quantum state of a single system in
isolation has been established.
Here's the definition. A quantum state of a system is represented by a column vector whose indices are placed
in correspondence with the
classical states of that system.
So we're assuming here that
the system we're talking about has some set of classical states, just like when we talked
about classical information
and probabilistic states. The entries in a quantum state
vector are complex numbers as opposed to the probabilistic case
where the entries are
non-negative real numbers.
And this time, the sum of the absolute
values squared of the entries must equal one as opposed to the sum being equal to one
as we have in the probabilistic case.
The complex numbers that appear
in a quantum state vector are sometimes called amplitudes and they play a role that's
similar to probabilities,
but they aren't probabilities and they don't have the
same interpretation.
Now, I can't give you a good reason for why quantum states
should be defined like this other than to say that
physicists have discovered
that this definition
is physically relevant and it allows us to describe and model
quantum mechanical systems.
In other words, we choose this definition
because it works, not because there are
any particular reasons why quantum states should
be defined like this.
With respect to the
mathematics of this notion of a quantum state, the first step towards understanding it and working with it is
to recall this definition
for the Euclidean norm of a vector, which you can think of geometrically as the length of a vector, just like you would think about the length
of a two-dimensional real vector if you drew it on a piece
of paper as an arrow starting from the origin in the usual way.